bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
auditions publiques l'émission
hebdomadaire politique commune la
République Sénat et la Chaîne
Parlementaire tous les lundis à 19h30
septembre a été calme sur le front
social relativement mais le feu Couvet
sous la braise sans doute aujourd'hui le
climat donne des sueurs froides au
gouvernement avec ses grèves ses
revendications sur les salaires cette
colère dont personne ne sait sur quoi
elle va déboucher bonsoir Laurent Berger
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes l'homme que l'on voulait
entendre ce soir vous êtes le patron du
1er syndicat de France faut-il le
rappeler la CFDT qui signe récemment un
accord avec Total quand la CGT le
rejette et bloque la CFDT qui réclame
depuis des mois on nous a beaucoup
entendu des négociations de salaire
quand des entreprises tarde peut-être à
embrayer la CFDT qui ne veut pas de la
réforme des retraites du gouvernement
quand Emmanuel Macron la maintient
Brigitte boucher et Steve Jourdain vous
interrogeront sur les grèves en cours
Jean-Baptiste sémerdjian vous
interpellera sur des questions
d'actualité Yves triart tout à aussi
vous interrogera sur la politique et
notamment l'usage du 49-3 mais pas
seulement également votre ressenti sur
le climat en France enfin vous avez
accepté de débattre avec François
Patriat patron des sénateurs de la
majorité qui vous échangerez entre
autres sur la réforme des retraites
encore une fois que veut maintenir
Emmanuel Macron d'abord quelques
questions avant tout cela est-ce que
comme la première ministre hier soir sur
TF1 Elisabeth borne vous jugez pas
normal
c'est son expression elle a dit cannelle
ça pas normal la poursuite de la grève
dans les raffineries après qu'un accord
a été négocié conclus signé avec les
syndicats majoritaires dans la CFDT et
je crois que sur l'ensemble de ces de ce
qui se passe dans la période le rôle de
mon rôle c'est pas de de qualifier
normal pas normal mon rôle c'est
d'expliquer ce qui se passe il y a CFDT
a signé un accord après une négociation
avec Total elle a signé un accord sur
l'ensemble du groupe Total 14 000
salariés en France 14000 salariés à la
s'il y a un accord qui est augmentation
de 7% et il y avait déjà eu un accord
2022 augmentation des salaires de 7 % et
une prime qui va de 3000 à 6000 euros
c'est un accord majoritaire
maintenant que d'autres décident des
organisations qui ne sont pas
majoritaires sur l'ensemble de ce
périmètre des sites de poursuivre la
grève c'est leur droit moi je suis trop
attaché au droit de grève pour leur dire
donc vous dites pas que c'est pas normal
je dis que il faut replacer les choses
comme elles sont la CFDT a fait son
travail de syndicalis c'est une en fait
moi je sais pas si c'est normal ou pas
normal ce que je sais c'est que c'est
pas la même conception du syndicalisme
que nous
les français
vous leur dites on a signé un accord
majoritaire qui amène un certain nombre
d'augmentations et de primes tout de
suite d'ailleurs pour les salariés et
puis la grève continue alors avoir à
quoi ça sert à quoi ça sert un accord
majoritaire qui ne permet pas de
déboucher sur un dénouement de cancer
pour 14000 salariés d'avoir une
augmentation de 7 % d'avoir une prime
qui équivaut à minima à 3000 euros et ce
que je dis c'est que la CFDT et les
militants CFDT de Total ont fait leur
travail de syndicaliste qui est
d'améliorer la situation des
travailleurs de Total et maintenant
d'autres organisations font d'autres
choix moi je peux vous dire toutes les
tous les commentaires non je trouve que
ça respectueux d'un accord qui a été je
trouve pas ça logique et je vais vous
dire j'ai entendu ce matin Philippe
Martinez sur France Inter dire cet
accord il faut la preuve qu'il est pas
majoritaire puisque il y a encore des
salariés qui sont majoritairement en
grève faux sur 14 000 salariés faut
archi faux
peut-être moins de 300 donc faut en plus
il dit bah puisque ces accords là
faudrait les soumettre à référendum dans
l'entreprise mais là c'est stérile balle
dans le pied quand on est dans son
syndicale à quoi sert aujourd'hui la
négociation collective et la négociation
sociale aussi une entreprise il faut
soumettre l'accord des organisations qui
je le rappelle des élections ont eu lieu
je crois que c'était en mars avril avec
c'est vrai une progression de la CFDT
mais donc un accord qui est majoritaire
signé par deux organisations syndicales
qui apportent des avancées concrètes
parce qu'au final c'est pas tellement la
polémique qui m'intéresse moi c'est ce
que ça apporte aux travailleurs et aux
travailleuses de chez Total il y a une
augmentation salariale qui est
conséquente ça veut pas dire que c'est
la fin de l'histoire on sait pas ce qui
se passera l'an prochain dans les mois à
venir il y a même une clause de revoyure
prévue en janvier si les choses devaient
s'emballer au niveau de l'inflation mais
moi vous savez ce qui m'importe c'est
pas que les syndicalistes y fassent de
l'agitation ce qui m'apporte c'est
qu'ils obtiennent des des avancées pour
ceux pour qui ils travaillent
normalement ils s'investissent
c'est-à-dire les travailleurs et
travailleuses vous comprenez que quand
on vous entend parce que c'est fort ce
que vous dites on a 14000 salariés qui
vont effectivement bénéficier d'un
accord que les syndicats majoritaires
ont signés il y en a moins de 300 qui
bloquent tout il y a des gens qui font
la queue pendant 2h30 pour remplir leur
et ben écoutez alors on se disent mais
alors c'est un dévoiement c'est un
dévoiement quand même je crois que je
crois que ça fait pas du bien au
syndicalise vous savez je crois que le
syndicalisme c'est ça se mesure
aux avancées que ça obtient pour les
salariés qu'il représente et pas au
niveau d'emmerdement qu'il crée pour les
Français mais
sur cette affaire là vous pouvez
constater classer FDT elle est plutôt
dans la première catégorie c'est-à-dire
les avancées qu'elle est aucun pour les
salariés concernant les emmerdements
pour les Français malheureusement c'est
pas de mon ressort alors on a compris
on a compris que vous regrettiez
cette action menée par la CGT vous allez
parler de Philippe Martinez on peut
nommer syndicat qui préside et qui
bloque les raffineries malgré l'accord
on va y revenir bien sûr avec Brigitte
boucher et Steve Jourdain qui se sont
assis en face de vous encore une
question je souhaite que cette grève
s'arrête ça c'est aussi la phrase
d'Elisabeth borne
est-ce que le gouvernement fait ce qu'il
faut
le gouvernement
berger
dans votre émission sur lesquelles je
vais le démontrer assez facilement je
suis pas en accord avec le gouvernement
après il y a tout il peut pas tout quand
même c'est pas moi c'est pas de moi
d'ailleurs cette phrase sur l'état peut
pas tout mais là il y a un conflit
salarial de l'entreprise qui qui qui
s'enquises malgré un accord majoritaire
que peut le gouvernement sur cette
affaire là pas grand chose ce qu'il faut
surtout pas c'est l'escalade donc il y a
des réquisitions moi je suis pour le
droit de grève les réquisitions ça doit
être très encadré mais c'est clair je
veux dire aujourd'hui enfin la situation
je la regrette moi je la regrette s'il y
avait pas eu je vais vous dire un truc
c'est s'il y avait pas eu d'accord
salarial chez Total un CFDT serait dans
ce mouvement potentiellement mais il y
en a eu un oui c'est on n'est pas dans
une situation de blocage de non
d'augmentation on a une augmentation de
salaire dans cette entreprise il y a un
sujet pour Total qui est posé par
ailleurs c'est le sujet de sa
contribution ou bien commun on va en
parler
des réquisitions de nouvelles
réquisitions au lieu aujourd'hui pour
vous c'est un outil légitime réquisition
actuellement c'est un outil légal vous
savez moi je suis républicain ça veut
dire que je crois à la loi et donc c'est
un outil légal est-ce que c'est la
meilleure manière de finir un conflit je
trouve que non et donc je je suis
attaché comme vous le savez au droit de
grève qui a un droit constitutionnel et
donc il faut que il y a eu un sur
l'Organisation internationale du Travail
a été saisie sur un certain nombre de
cas liés aux réquisition et elle dit
bien que ça doit être utilisée en
situation extrême c'est en situation
mais là c'est le cas aujourd'hui
il faut il faut bien que les enfants
aillent à l'école il faut bien qu'il y
ait de la des services d'urgence donc ça
ça doit s'organiser après pour le reste
je sais pas mais vous savez aujourd'hui
que c'est légitime vous savez la
situation
la situation qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui c'est que moi je suis juste
un syndicaliste c'est déjà pas mal mais
c'est juste un syndicaliste c'est vrai
elle responsable de la première
organisation syndicale française qui sur
ce coup-là a fait son travail sur ce
coup-là a fait son job nos militants moi
j'en suis très fier des militants de
total ils ont assumé leur part de
responsabilité y compris en ayant
conscience je peux vous le dire le
délégué syndical central avec lequel
j'ai beaucoup échangé ces derniers jours
en ayant une haute conscience de la des
conséquences de ce qui se passait sur
les citoyens à partir de quand vous
estimerez que qu'il y a une atteinte au
droit des rêves
la CGT en fait demande aujourd'hui 10%
d'augmentation de salaire vous vous avez
obtenu dans cet accord majoritaire 7%
plus une prime un bonus d'un mois la CGT
estime qu'il y a encore un peu de grains
moudre est-ce que c'est exagéré de
demander 10% d'augmentation de salaire
pour une entreprise qui a fait de très
gros profits mais de ce point de vue là
rien n'est exagéré dans ce cas là mais
c'est le jeu de la négociation
collective vous savez il y a une
entreprise qui est en grève qu'on
connaît bien tous ici depuis le 11
octobre qui s'appelle Lubrizol cette
fameuse entreprise ou malheureusement il
y avait eu un une explosion ils sont en
grève dans une intersey syndicale
d'ailleurs entre la CGT et la CFDT il
réclame une entreprise qui a fait
beaucoup de bénéfices ces dernières
années et une revendication syndicale
qui est d'augmentation de 7%. et la
grève elle intervient pourquoi parce que
il y a eu des négociations durant
lesquelles l'employeur n'a rien voulu
céder
donc
pas à la hauteur
mais est-ce que Patrick pouyanet
chez Total 14000 salariés chez Total il
y a des millions de salariés dans le
privé aujourd'hui il y a des millions de
salariés dont on parle pas et ça c'est
je vais vous dire c'est au bout d'un
moment les jours que nous sommes en
train de vivre là ça invisibilise
totalement des salariés dont on parle
jamais vous savez ces fameux
travailleurs de la deuxième ligne ce qui
ont été là pendant tout le confinement à
qui on a dit vous allez avoir une
augmentation de salaire et bien cela
nous on essaie de les organiser pour
qu'ils aient des augmentations de
salaire c'est demain demain il y a un
mouvement dans les EHPAD dans les EHPAD
privés je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
française autour de la situation de
Total
je dis qu'il faut et aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de conflictualité sur les
salaires à peu près partout dans
beaucoup d'entreprises et aussi
également dans la fonction publique mais
toutes les associations sont légitimes
et toutes les grèves sont légitimes bah
oui bien sûr la preuve la CFDT emmène
beaucoup mais pourquoi vous m'interrogez
simplement sur total pourquoi c'est une
résolution le problème c'est pour ça
total c'est aujourd'hui un accord
salarial chez Total et vous me demandez
si on pourrait si ça serait bien qu'il
est salariés ont plus les salariés
évidemment c'est important qu'ils aient
plus
mais ils sont pas mis fin à la grève il
y a 14000 salariés chez Total il y a
combien de personnes en grève
aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous craignez que Patrick
pouyanet cède à la CGT accord 10% de
salaire pour mettre fin à la grève non
mais il y a un accord qui est à la fois
des organisations
pas mais ça serait ça serait totalement
maître par terre la démocratie sociale
et le dialogue social dans une
entreprise le gouvernement annoncé la
prolongation de la ristour de 30
centimes à la pompe jusqu'à la
mi-novembre parce que 15 jours c'est
suffisant selon vous
vous savez moi je suis pour le
concernant les aides à la pompe je suis
pour les aides ciblées depuis le début
je pense que
alors là il y a on voit bien qu'il y a
une situation exceptionnelle il y a une
prolongation mais d'ailleurs le FMI qui
vient de sortir un rapport montre bien
que concernant les aides au ménage les
plus modestes concernant enfin les aides
concernant la hausse de l'inflation il
faut davantage cibler les aides depuis
le début avec cette prime à la pompe moi
je dis que c'est pas totalement logique
qu'on finance la même chose pour
quelqu'un qui va rejoindre sa résidence
secondaire et j'ai rien contre les gens
qui ont des résistances secondaires le
week-end que on va faire que pour perdre
quelqu'un qui va tous les jours faire 30
km pour aller à son travail dans tel ou
tel pour suivre cette aide pour les plus
modestes oui je pense qu'il faudrait
pour les notamment pour les salariés ce
que je représente il faudrait pouvoir
poursuivre cette aide pour se rendre
notamment au travail jusqu'à ceux qui
sont contraints d'utiliser lors de leur
véhicule personnel jusqu'à quand vous
savez là on a un problème un problème
spécifique qui est pas ça qui est
temporaire on l'espère avec l'inflation
mais pour l'instant il est il est réel
avec un coup du carburant qui a certes
baissé mais qui est encore en qui est en
train de repartir à la hausse ces
jours-ci donc vous avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est pas mais moi plus que
jusqu'à quand c'est comment on cible
davantage que vous étiez pas toujours
d'accord avec le gouvernement Emmanuel
Macron avait dit que il y aurait un
retour à la normale pour le carburant
dans le courant de cette semaine ce
matin Clément Beaune a dit que ce serait
plutôt pour la semaine prochaine on a vu
aussi Olivier Véran qui n'avait pas vu
les pénuries alors est-ce que vous dites
qu'on est face à un gouvernement qui est
déconnecté ou pas
sur ce sujet là en particulier j'en sais
rien sur une part de la colère qui
gronde dans notre pays notamment sur la
question du pouvoir de vivre décemment
de son travail oui il y a une part de
déconnexion ça fait combien de temps que
je répète qu'il y a un problème de
salaire dans ce pays et de branche je
regarde madame Martichoux parce que je
crois qu'elle vous l'avoir dit au moins
10 fois et ici aussi c'est combien de
temps et quel est le levier sur lequel
le gouvernement peut agir pas les
augmentations de salaire dans les
entreprises c'est pas vrai ça
il peut intervenir en conditionnant une
partie des aides publiques qu'il verse
son entreprise en disant vous devez
avoir une politique salariale digne de
ce nom et notamment des relèvements des
minimas de branches pour c'est puisque
le public mais oui il y a une part de
déconnexion et après sur les délais
quand on sait pas vaut mieux s'abstenir
de de faire des promesses c'est je pense
que c'est de bonne c'est de bon usage
c'est la galère pour beaucoup de
Français on leur a compris vous dites
quoi au patron il serait tenté de
sanctionner leur salarié qui ne viennent
pas au travail faut de défense non mais
j'espère qu'elle n'aura pas beaucoup et
j'ose croire qu'il y en aura pas
c'est dégueulasse
on pourrait rien ouais moi aujourd'hui
non mais ce serait quand même logique
que les entreprises peuvent se soucier
d'ailleurs pas que dans cette cause dans
la situation actuelle on le dit depuis
longtemps d'organiser du covoiturage des
transports collectifs etc mais moi je ça
relève du domaine de la philosophie
parce que si ça arrive on le sent on
dénoncera ces chefs d'entreprise qui
sanctionneraient des salariés bah on
demande ce serait ce serait anormal
alors justement une proposition de loi à
ce sujet le texte prévoit que
l'impossibilité de faire le plein
d'essence soit considéré comme un motif
légitime d'absence au travail c'est une
bonne idée
moi vous savez je crois que la loi c'est
quelque chose de très très fort
légiférer sur le dernier le dernier truc
qui est arrivé le hier ou avant-hier
non mais là aussi vous j'aime pas
tellement mal caricaturer parce que vous
voyez bien je vais dire finir par avoir
que des ennemis mais c'est pas que je
charge les amis d'ailleurs j'en ai
suffisamment mais le je pense qu'il faut
arrêter avec ça c'est à dire que là
l'idéal c'est que chacun puisse faire le
plein de de son véhicule lorsqu'il en a
besoin
pour se rendre au travail etc et que les
patrons soient humains de la
compréhension mais vous savez il y en a
plus qu'on ne le croit il y en a plus
qu'on ne le croit et puis il y a un truc
qui s'est développé alors certes que
pour 30% des salariés il s'appelle le
télétravail donc ça permet d'aménager
pour certains mais mais oui moi j'ai
rencontré la semaine dernière à Vesoul
des des travailleurs des salariés qui ne
pouvaient plus qu'il me disait-il le
lendemain n'allait plus pouvoir se
rendre à leur travail par faute de
carburant dans ces cas là ça pose un
vrai problème problème et je pense que
tout ça faut que ça cesse faut que ça
cesse je le dis comme je le pense
leader communiste donc
oui de toute façon c'est toujours le cas
c'est à dire que je crois que surtout
qu'il faut avoir la culture du compromis
dans notre pays c'est quand même assez
peu partagé je dois le dire mais encore
une fois la on n'aurait pas obtenu un
accord chez Total mais il y a 7 %
d'augmentation et et une prime qui va
3000 à 6000 euros on le dira jamais
assez et et aujourd'hui on a plein de
conflits salariaux on a plein dans les
entreprises c'est ça que je voudrais que
le patronat comprenne c'est peut-être un
avertissement ce sera peut-être
finalement un avertissement utile au
patronat c'est que il ne joue pas la
montre sur les négociations mais qui
décide de s'engager réellement dans des
négociations partout où il y a
aujourd'hui des conflits j'ai pas parlé
de Groupama j'ai pas parlé de Socotec et
un cabinet d'études
parce qu'il y a une grande journée de
mobilisation interprofessionnelle sur
les salaires et vous vous y êtes pas
pourquoi et vous savez une journée de
demain et l'invisent les salariés de
Socotec elle invisibilise les salariés
des EHPAD elle invisibilise laissez-moi
finir s'il vous plaît elle invisibilise
les salariés de Groupama tout vous savez
pourquoi parce qu'on va pas en parler
demain
ou que le patron de ce côté il va pas
passer sous les radars et il va se dire
bonne nouvelle vous n'allez pas dire aux
cheminots ne faites pas grave parce que
sinon on ne parlera pas des autres je
dis pas ça non je dis pas du tout ça je
dis que faire croire que l'action
syndicale pour l'augmentation des
salaires c'est d'organiser des grandes
manifestations interprofessionnelles je
vais vous dire
non je vais vous dire les salariés n'y
croient pas les salariés moi j'ai
rencontré j'étais sur j'étais sur un
piquet de grève il y a 10 jours à ça ou
12 jours à Cergy-Pontoise dans une
entreprise s'appelle arc-en-ciel qui est
une entreprise de nettoyage les salariés
réclamaient plusieurs choses notamment
un treizième mois il réclame avec les
heures sup soit payés les heures
supplémentaires soient payées ils
réclamait du matériel pour travailler
correctement puis le réclamait aussi et
ils l'ont eu deux
sauf évidemment sauf et dans les
branchés d'entreprise donc ça comprend
les gens de la SNCF ça comprend les gens
de la RATP ça comprend évidemment les
agents publics donc c'est dans les
secteurs professionnels qu'il faut
essayer de se battre demain il y a un
mouvement dans le public est-ce que vous
savez que demain il y a un mouvement
dans le public sur la ce qu'on appelle
la voie professionnelle dans les lycées
professionnels il y a un mouvement à
terre syndical parce que il y a des
discussions qui s'op qui commence à se
faire sur l'évolution du lycée
professionnel et et bien les les les
collègues de la CFDT de l'enseignement
de l'éducation nationale ou
l'enseignement privé soit en mouvement
pour essayer d'expliquer qu'il faudrait
maintenir un certain nombre d'heures
comme ça où ça négocier où il y a des
problèmes il peut y avoir une sorte de
convergence des luttes une coagulation
de cette colère à partir des salaires
non comment ça c'est le mythe de la
grève générale
la convergence des luttes c'est autre
chose que un objet commun pour agir pour
agir ensemble donc c'est comment on le
connaît ça existait en 2010 c'est c'est
le le
la réforme de retraite ça existait en
2006 avec le contrat premier embauche là
parce que vous avez un objet commun là
aujourd'hui l'objet commun c'est des
augmentations salariales mais ça ne se
passe ça se passe dans les secteurs
professionnels et dans les entreprises
et moi il y a une chose c'est pas que je
crois pas c'est que je voudrais pas
laisser croire que la combativité
syndicale c'est les manifestations
sautent-moutons de de quelques dizaines
de militants la mobilisation syndicale
c'est entreprise par entreprise pour
négocier des augmentations de salaire je
vais vous raconter une histoire
Français du Sang les militants CFDT les
établissements français du sang
organisme s'il en est extrêmement utile
à notre société se battent depuis des
mois et des mois et des mois pour une
augmentation salariale la semaine
dernière ils ont obtenu 3,5%. et bien je
vais vous dire c'est sans doute
insuffisant mais sans leur combativité
syndicale ça n'aurait pas existé avec à
minima 100 euros d'augmentation pour
chaque salarié sur la compatibilité
syndicale des salaires est-ce que vous
êtes pour indexer les salaires sur
l'inflation ça a été supprimé par
Mitterrand en 83 est-ce que vous êtes
pour le rétablissement de ces indexation
mais moi je suis pour qu'il y ait
contrairement à ce que j'ai entendu ce
matin et compris de la part de Philippe
Martinez sur France Inter il dit la CFDT
elle veut pas de cadre légal mais elle
veut un cadre légal CFDT elle se garde
légale ça s'appelle le SMIC le SMIC a
été revalorisé depuis Etienne oui mais
qu'un excès sur sur l'inflation et qui
était c'est une très bonne chose et
après je suis pour la vivacité du
dialogue social donc pas pour une annexe
générale
une bonne chose tout simplement parce
que le jour où vous avez ce mécanisme là
et que l'inflation baisse et revient à
ce qu'on a connu précédemment ce qui
peut arriver dans
mais c'est un truc de c'est un truc de
dingue en fait on se fait jamais
confiance pour le compromis et donc on
changera la loi quoi et et ce jour-là si
vous avez un essai sur la création avec
une inflation de 2% et ben ça veut dire
que ça aurait été des augmentations
salariales les années précédentes de 3
ou 4 % qu'on a obtenu ici ou là par la
négociation par la négociation et la
mobilisation alors les retraites le
cycle de négociation a commencé on voit
que le spectre d'un amendement au plfs
c'est éloigné vous êtes vous dans quel
état d'esprit au moment de négocier
cette réforme vous avez pas beaucoup de
temps hein
c'est pas un accord à la fin c'est
différent justement d'accord salarial où
il y a un compromis
l'état d'esprit c'est d'abord un
soulagement que ce soit pas passé par le
PLFSS j'ai juste quand même à tous ceux
notamment au gouvernement qui disait la
CFDT elle veut repousser le truc
imaginez si on était en ce moment dans
le contexte actuel avec un amendement au
pfss pour faire 64 ou 65 ans je vous
laisse imaginer le bazar et là on aurait
un objet commun pour la convergence ça
s'appellerait un amendement
donc là c'est une concertation vous en
attendez quoi du coup
d'abord ces trois étapes la première
c'est sur les seigneurs et les fins de
carrière on en attend beaucoup de choses
vous savez que l'équilibre des retraites
c'est à peu près 10 milliards de
déficits dans les années à venir par an
sur 320 milliards versés tous les ans
c'est 3% 3% de ce qui est versé tous les
ans quand vous êtes à 3% de découvert à
la fin du mois votre banquier même s'il
est sévère il vous met pas un interdit
bancaire donc il y a des choses à
regarder et comment on peut le financer
notamment parce qu'on mettrait plus de
seniors en emploi 30% d'emplois des
seniors en France 70% le taux d'emploi
des seniors en Suède ils ont moins de
problèmes que nous c'est normal ils
gardent les seniors donc le premier
sujet c'est celui-là comment on fait en
sorte de garder les seniors avec dedans
la question de de départ progressifs en
retraite il y a le sujet du cumul emploi
retraite qui est sur la table donc nous
on veut des avancées concrètes surtout
ces sujets là le deuxième sujet ce sera
sur les sujets des pénibilités sur les
sujets de de oui des carrières longues
donc on voudra travailler on veut
travailler sur sur des l'amélioration
des dispositifs de pénibilité réintégrer
les pénibilités qui avaient été enlevées
en 2017 et ensuite il y aura le
gouvernement vote la troisième sujet qui
sera le sujet d'équilibre j'espère que
d'ici là on aura montré à travers les
seniors que le sujet de l'équilibre
qu'on décide qu'on veut bien aborder
c'est pas qu'il y en a pas besoin c'est
que si on peut le combler avec le sujet
par exemple des seniors donc on va
essayer de faire cette démonstration là
que ceux qui n'essayent pas qu'il y
arrive jamais vous avez pas voté l'âge
de départ à la retraite c'est pas un
sujet pour vous l'exécutif veut
repousser à 64 65 ans pour vous il y a
rien à négocier pas de compromis
possible là-dessus non il a pas d'abord
encore une fois on négocie pas parce que
si on négocie
oui mais c'est très important il n'y a
pas de compromis possibles non il y a
pas de compromis possible sur le report
de la gegal pourquoi parce que ça
concernerait d'abord ce qu'on commençait
à travailler tôt ça concernerait parce
que je rappelle quand même que l'âge
légal et 62 ans mais le départ moyen
c'est 63 ans et 62 ans ça permet quoi ça
permet à ce qu'on commençait à
travailler tôt de partir à 62 ans ça
permet de à tous ceux qui ont des
carrières hachées des métiers pénibles
de partir à 62 ans ça permet à ces
travailleurs de deuxième ligne qu'on a
mobilisé remobiliser
si on prendrait bien que je ferai pas le
compromis sur le public Sénat si jamais
il devait en avoir un bah parce que
c'est quand même pas lieu de l'année
et bien compris et je le ferai pas ici
et encore une fois pour la CFDT on croit
pas qu'il y a une mesure d'âge à prendre
quelle qu'elle soit pour aller
combler le déficit encore une fois où il
y a il y a pas le feu au lac il y a pas
le feu
vous avez vu votre présence
ils ont dit il faudra augmenter l'âge
légal de départ en retraite parce qu'il
faut financer d'autres choses sur le
financement de l'éducation de la santé
etc et puis depuis on met les freins
pourquoi parce que les Français ils se
disent mais
oui quand on travaille et celui qui vous
le dit c'est un responsable à CFDT qui
en 2003 en 2013 a assumé sa parole
des retraites en 203 en 2013 le déficit
c'était la mise à mal la mise en danger
la disparition potentielle de ce
merveille cette merveilleux système qui
est le système de retraite par les
partitions c'est plus le cas la plus
danger de mort c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
aucune aucune la question
c'est rien qui justifie une mesure
brutale après 2023 il y aurait quand
même un déficit vous avez dit qu'on
pouvait jouer sur la fiscalité qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que vous entendez parler
est-ce que ça peut passer par une
augmentation des cotisations pour vous
non je dis sur la fiscalité je voulais
veut dire que ça peut passer le
financement de l'éducation ça passe par
la fiscalité de la santé ça passe pas
fiscalité c'est ça que je voulais dire
les retraites travailler plus longtemps
ou travailler le temps nécessaire c'est
juste si il y a besoin pour travailler
pour financer le système de retraite par
étape augmentation des cotisations pour
vous c'est pas
je suis dans une forme de réalisme un
gouvernement qui refuse qui essaie de
baisser toutes les contributions et tout
et tout et toute la fiscalité allez à
une augmentation de cotisation ça
m'étonnerait
du Mondial de foot au Qatar vous allez
le regarder vous allez voir mais j'ai
pas le regarder mais je trouve que tout
ça j'adore le foot et je trouve que tout
ça est déprimant sur justement ce que je
pense du parfois du traitement de de du
débat public je vais vous dire lorsque
ça a été attribué je crois en 2013
la Confédération syndicale
internationale a fait une campagne pour
dénoncer et pour demander de revoter
y compris en justifiant de la situation
des travailleurs qui avant même ce
Mondial étaient faites au Qatar des
travailleurs migrants
tout le monde à ce moment-là est passé
et maintenant on vient au Qatar la Coupe
du monde elle va malheureusement avoir
lieu au Qatar moi je la regarderai pas
parce que j'aime trop le sport pour
renier mes valeurs en clairement le
sport mais ceci étant on aurait mieux
fait de se réveiller plus tôt merci
beaucoup Steve et Brigitte dans un
instant nous rejoindre mais d'abord on
va rejoindre
bonsoir Jean-Baptiste merci d'être avec
nous vous avez une question à Laurent
Berger oui bonsoir Laurent Berger alors
vous en avez parlé l'actualité est
marquée par les grèves qui font craindre
pour certains un retour des gilets
jaunes et pourtant hier la marge de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'assemblée que 30
000 personnes selon la préfecture de
police de Paris comment vous à la CDT
vous percevez cette crise de
représentativité est-ce que vous pensez
toujours pouvoir représenter la classe
populaire qui elle est vraiment
invisibilisée vous parliez
d'invisbilisation la classe populaire
est vraiment invisible
non elle est pas invisibilisée elle est
pas invisibilisée par mon organisation
je peux vous le dire nous on a organisé
des marches de travailleurs de deuxième
ligne en mars en février et mars dernier
ça a été assez peu couvert si je peux me
permettre
ça a été même
il y a eu quelques quelques dépêche etc
mais on en a pas fait à ce moment-là une
espèce de de on n'a pas pris je crois
tout le monde n'a pas pris conscience
que là il y avait des rassemblements il
y avait deux ou trois mille personnes
qui venaient des travailleurs de la
propreté de la distribution du commerce
etc donc ils sont pas invisibilisés nous
le week-end dernier il y a encore une un
mouvement de protestation à Monoprix
parce qu'il y a pas d'augmentation
salariale donc cette crise de la
représentative
de la représentativité c'est
oui mais ça il y a d'autres raisons la
une des raisons vous savez en Belgique
si vous n'avez pas vous n'êtes pas
syndiqué vous avez pas d'assurance
chômage dans les pays nordiques si vous
n'êtes pas syndiqué vous bénissez pas
des accords qui sont signés
collectivement et je crois qu'il faut
arrêter de taper la CFDT c'est 600000
adhérents aucun parti politique j'ai
presque envie de dire à peu près aucun
journal n'a pas autant il y a combien de
lecteurs potentiels du Figaro et et donc
non mais vous voyez bien au bout d'un
moment on va faire on peut jouer il y a
le dernier sondage du Cevipof la
dernière enquête du CV prof et de la
Fondation Jean Jaurès qui montre que le
taux de confiance dans les organisations
syndicales il a il a augmenté il est 38%
j'ose pas vous donner celui des médias
ni même des parlementaires et moi je
m'en réjouis je vais vous dire
franchement je m'en réjouis pas mais ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que c'est
pas c'est pas la bonne clé d'entrée pour
parler de ce que le déficit démocratique
aujourd'hui la bonne clé d'entrée c'est
ceux qui doivent assumer leur part de
responsabilité ils sont élus il y a des
élus il y a la société civile mais bien
sûr les syndicats sont faibles en France
quand même les syndicats il y a pas
assez d'adhérents dans les organisations
syndicales mais je peux vous assurer que
regarde l'Europe on trouve qu'il y a peu
de syndiqués en France mais on trouve
que justement ils ont une espèce de
force vous voyez ça fait quand même une
demi-heure qu'on discute pour essayer de
m'expliquer que les syndicats se
rencontrent tout bloquer donc soit ils
sont faits ils sont forts mais il faut
qu'on se dise souvent d'accord
Jean-Baptiste à tout à l'heure et vous
il y a pas assez d'adhérents dans les
organisations syndicales et que on y en
aura plus le jour on fera la
démonstration beaucoup plus visible de
la de ce qu'on leur apporte comme
résultat à tout à l'heure Jean-Baptiste
Yves Thréard bonjour directeur adjoint
la rédaction du Figaro on vous écoute
bonsoir Laurent Berger deux petites
questions deux ou trois petites
questions sur le budget quand même on en
a un peu parlé si on est en pleine en
plein débat budgétaire est-ce qu'à votre
avis le gouvernement doit de toute
manière passer par le 49-3 pour la faire
adopter ça vous savez j'ai suffisamment
de soucis pour pas m'en préoccuper c'est
pas mon c'est pas mon problème ça dit
quoi de la société politique et de la
bonne du débat politique actuel
ça dit qu'il y a pas de majorité absolue
et qu'il y a besoin de trouver des
compromis qui sont à peu près
introuvables dans l'état du débat
politique aujourd'hui alors c'est
intéressant mais je trouve ça mais je
trouve vrai franchement je trouverais
problématique que le débat public
s'organise autour de l'utilisation ou
non de ce 49-3 et pas de ce contenu du
PLF le contenu du PNF moi j'ai deux
critiques si je peux le faire vous voyez
allez-y c'est au-delà du 49-3 la
première c'est que ça ne transpire
transcrit pas un budget ambitieux pour
faire face à un mur qui est devant nous
c'est celui de la transition écologique
d'accord il y a pas assez
d'investissement le deuxième c'est que
ce budget il souffre d'un dogme qui est
la baisse de la contribution des uns et
des autres au bien commun c'est à dire
la baisse de la fiscalité et on le voit
par exemple avec la baisse des impôts de
production je crois pas que ce soit le
moment alors vous faites mes bonnes
transitions parce que c'est ce que vous
en prenez est-ce qu'on n'est pas
actuellement dans une société qui est en
plein malaise qui est sous pression
finalement avec effectivement de débats
qui sont très importants le premier
c'est sur les super profits et avec une
espèce de d'atmosphère si vous me
permettez de lutte des classes on va
casser on va saccager les Grimes de golf
on veut plus que des gens
voyagent avec des avions privés avec des
jets privés on va crever les pneus de
voiture de SUV ce qu'on appelle des SUV
on va taguer des endroits qui sont
considérés comme des endroits de riches
donc il y a ça et puis il y a aussi des
supers profits font certaines sociétés
quand même et qui ne pensent pas
tellement au salaire de leur de leurs
employés et puis cette transition
écologique moi je trouve que elle est
inquiétante parce que cette transition
écologique finalement elle remet en
question complètement les modes de
production et on va peut-être au devant
d'années de chômage d'années de
mécontentement salariale parce que
justement et bien on n'a pas anticipé
tout ça alors quel est votre question
alors ma première question c'est sûr les
super profits est-ce qu'on est dans une
atmosphère de lutte des classes non on
est dans une phosphère où il y a un
besoin une aspiration à à l'égalité à la
justice sociale qui est beaucoup plus
forte vous je crois que vous vous mettez
sur le même plan des choses qui sont pas
qui sont pas similaires
crever les voitures de quelqu'un c'est
illégal et c'est pas les pneus c'est
voilà c'est nul enfin je vais lui dire
comme ça mais
posez la question de l'utilisation de
jet privé même si c'est symbolique ça
vous résoudra pas là qui sont la
traduction écologique c'est pas
totalement c'est pas totalement anormal
c'est pas totalement anormal pourquoi
parce que aujourd'hui oui il y a un
sujet de répartition de la richesse
créée et la contribution des uns et des
autres au bien commun qui est posé et ce
débat là on devrait l'avoir de façon
apaisée d'ailleurs personne n'a à lui
sous-sol la solution de ce qu'il
faudrait faire en termes de fiscalité
mais oui il y a besoin de revoir la
faudra éviter
quand même il y a pas trop de défi il y
a pas trop d'écart il faudrait pas sinon
à finir par vraiment
le non le vrai sujet le vrai sujet sur
les super profits oui c'est un peu comme
la proposition de loi dont on m'a parlé
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que c'est
adhérents CFDT et
objectivement je sens une inquiétude
très forte sur un double un des sujets
que vous avez évoqué c'est à dire on
sait quand on a des transformations
devant nous qui sont extrêmement
importantes une capacité à pouvoir vivre
correctement de plus en plus difficile
pour certains pas pour tout le monde
encore une fois pas pour tout le monde
mais qui sont pas que des questions de
revenus du travail qui sont des
questions aussi de capacité à se loger à
se déplacer à pouvoir faire face là à la
facture énergétique vous savez les 15 il
y a un bouclier on est dans on est dans
un pays qui protège les citoyens et
heureusement avec le bouclier
énergétique mais moi j'étais avec des
agents publics le jour où il y a eu
cette annonce de 15% versus 120%
normalement le coût le coût réel il y
avait des gens qui avaient à la fois
confiance qu'on était dans un pays qui
protégeait et puis on voit on voyait
quand même des agents notamment les
agents de catégoriques qui commencent à
se dire
les 15% si on est sur le fil ça va nous
faire basculer du mauvais côté donc faut
prendre conscience de ça c'est moi il
faut écouter respirer le pays
est-ce qu'il faut changer le modèle de
société
non mais je crois que les changements je
crois qu'il faut d'abord expliquer que
la perspective c'est effectivement un
évolution nos modèles productif sans
doute un certain nombre d'usages
d'occasion nous on a fait un rapport sur
le avec la Fédération pour la Nature et
l'Homme et et la CFDT dans le cadre du
collectif qu'on appelle le pack du
pouvoir de vivre qui est 65 associations
avec lesquelles on travaille qui montre
que l'évolution du modèle automobile par
exemple faut dire la chose aux salariés
la transformation on sait on voit que
ces jours-ci c'était lentis ou Renault
transforme leur usine pour aller vers
l'électrique on sait tous qu'il y aura
potentiellement des impacts sur les
emplois sur les compétences en a deux
choix on fait ceux qui veulent pas en
parler et qui nous voilons la face où on
prend les choses de face et on se dit
bah voilà et ça nécessitera d'investir
dans les transitions professionnelles en
finançant les transitions
professionnelles dans l'évolution des
compétences c'est fait dans
l'aménagement et territoire
insuffisamment et alors là c'est là où
on donne aussi le champ aux Chinois par
exemple on sur le véhicule électrique
qui sont très en avance sur nous et ça
c'est moins d'ailleurs le Salon de
l'automobile qui s'est ouvert
aujourd'hui oui mais ça ça prouve une
chose c'est que d'abord il faut savoir
anticiper et l'idée il est pas dans
notre pays de simplement de se dire
qu'est-ce qu'on a loupé potentiellement
et qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'on réussisse
demain et donc il y a tout un tas de de
de niveau notamment industriel vous
savez on a discuté de cela avec le
ministre de industrie l'a dit mais
trouvons des territoires où on peut
faire la démonstration qu'on peut avoir
une industrie qui se porte bien des
transitions professionnelles qui
s'opèrent en fait la période elle est
hyper anxiogène tout le monde le sait
elle est anxiogène pour des questions de
de court terme de capacité à vivre
correctement parce que la transition
écologique qui arrive parce que on est
quand même dans une forme de précarité
démocratique c'est-à-dire que le jeu
démocratique qui consiste à disqualifier
son interlocuteur pour prouver qu'on a
raison essayons d'aller sur le fond des
idées et de donner de la perspective
d'une transition juste de passer un
modèle de société apaisé je pense à peu
près à tout le monde en vrai ah non je
pense à peu près à tout le monde ouais
je suis désolé de vous le dire Monsieur
Philippe Martinez quand il dit enfin
quand tu n'es pas d'accord avec vous sur
non c'est vrai non non je vais vous dire
un truc c'est que avec Philippe Martinez
on n'est pas on est en désaccord sur
nombreux points tout le monde l'a
compris pas que on n'est pas que en
désaccord on a une vision assez partagé
sur l'évolution du travail etc mais vous
avez remarqué que on s'attaque jamais
personnellement dernière question non
alors
vous avez quand même un signe d'espoir
pour et bien que le pays ne sombre pas
justement dans une espèce de ce qui fait
de de bouillonnement
pré-révolutionnaire j'ai le mot sing
espoir c'est que il y a beaucoup de gens
qui attendent un débat public beaucoup
plus apaisé je crois que malheureusement
le débat public c'est parfois l'écume et
puis en profondeur les gens trouvent des
solutions entre eux sont capables de de
faire un certain nombre de choses sont
solidaires vous savez les pack du
pouvoir de vivre avec eux on parle il y
a 40 groupes locaux les gens qui ont
envie de faire vivre des solidarités
locales et puis on a un socle qui est
fort c'est notre modèle social et c'est
cette ce modèle social c'est des
services publics qui répondent aux
besoins des citoyens qui feraient formés
qu'il faut consolider on le voit bien
avec la santé ou l'éducation par exemple
et puis une protection sociale mais tout
ça ça peut évoluer on peut les faire
évoluer pour que ça réponde plus aux
besoins mais on a on a ce qu'il faut la
seule question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on est
capable de passer les compromis entre
nous parce que dans une démocratie les
intérêts des uns sont pas toujours les
intérêts des autres ce qui fait ce qu'il
fait du de parler
merci beaucoup avant de d'accueillir
merci beaucoup Yves la semaine prochaine
Patriat il y a un mot qui a pas encore
été prononcé depuis 50 minutes c'est
l'Ukraine la guerre en Ukraine alors ça
ajoute évidemment l'anxiété général on
va pas ouvrir ce chapitre cette évidence
une question il y en a dans le débat
public qui demande qu'on arrête d'aider
lucrènes contenu de la difficulté qu'on
a déjà aujourd'hui à soutenir les
compatriotes français ou leur dites quoi
je leur dis que c'est scandaleux
d'ailleurs c'est c'est ce serait tout
aussi scandaleux d'arrêter l'aide de
développement qui est déjà insuffisante
pour l'Afrique ce serait tout aussi
scandaleux mais là pour l'Ukraine
spécifiquement oui il faut les aider il
faut les aider d'abord à essayer de
combattre nous sommes au bord de la
récession éventuellement pas encore
maintenant mais ça peut venir il faut
continuer
et dans notre dans notre histoire dans
des grands moments de difficultés
individ collectif il y a eu des
solidarités et oui il faut continuer des
délukraine je vais vous dire il y a une
cagnotte à certains syndicale qui a été
créée pour aider les organisations
syndicales ukrainiennes pour qu'elles
aident elles-mêmes les travailleurs
Ukrainiens il y a un convoi
intersyndical qui va partir
en France il faut arrêter j'entends
beaucoup de solidarités beaucoup de
beaucoup de de de sens du commun pas que
du repli sur soi et si vous savez quand
il y a des stations de repli sur soi
parce que il y a un autre mot qu'on n'a
pas employé depuis un petit moment
maintenant c'est le rassemblement
national depuis le début de l'émission
oui ils peuvent récupérer les fruits de
ce qui est en train de se passer en
termes d'angoisse etc et bien si on veut
combattre ça il faut montrer des espaces
de solidarité des espaces de
construction du commun et ça passe y
compris à l'international par une
solidarité avec les Ukrainiens c'est
très ferme François Patriat bonsoir ravi
de vous accueillir merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté de débattre François
Patriat vous êtes le Patron des
sénateurs de renaissance la majorité
relative mais la toujours été quand même
et vous voulez aborder deux sujets avec
Laurent Berger
je vous ai écouté avec attention c'est
ce soir au cours de la semaine
précédente lors d'interview que vous
avez donné le matin sur les différentes
radios je voudrais revenir un instant
avant de parler des retraites sur deux
sujets que vous avez évoqué ce soir en
particulier d'abord vous dire que
j'apprécie votre sens du dialogue les
termes que vous venez de prononcer à
l'instant sur le dialogue apaisé dans ce
pays sur le service public que
j'apprécie tout cela et vous avez fait
preuve de responsabilité en signant
souvent des accords ce que d'autres
syndicats ne font jamais outre rarement
ou s'il est des accords et vous venez
dans montrer la positivité il y a une
question d'abord je reviens à l'instant
sur le fait que vous avez dit que vous
ne voulez pas d'escalade que l'accord
était signé mais pas d'escalade quand un
accord a été signé tout à l'heure
Elisabeth particault vous a posé la
question quand il a été signé c'est un
accord majoritaire qui doit s'imposer et
qu'il obtient des avancées très
importantes mais que certains grévistes
ne veulent pas le reconnaître et
continuer la grève
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire sinon la
réquisition et autrement reprocher au
gouvernement de ne pas être actif
non mais c'est j'ai pas dit que la
situation du gouvernement était facile
dans ce cas de figure ce que je dis
juste quand je parle de pas d'escalade
c'est qu'on n'est pas obligé d'employer
des mauxures vous savez dans le débat
public on peut être extrêmement ferme en
étant correct et je pense que oui il y a
des gens avec lesquels qui sont pas
d'accord avec moi je présume vous savez
dans la période on entend aussi pas mal
qui continue aujourd'hui un mouvement de
rêve dans les raffineries et je crois
que on puis on peut dire qu'on est en
désaccord avec ce la poursuite de ce
mouvement de grève sans pour autant
tomber dans la caricature en parlant
d'eux comme des gens extrémistes etc
je réponds pas à ça je réponds pas la à
la à la provocation y compris dans les
rapports dans les rapports syndicaux ou
dans les rapports humains mais juste
évidemment que il y a un sujet de
réquisition qui est posé au gouvernement
j'ai pas non plus dit mais pas entendu
dire que c'était une horreur absolue je
dis qu'il faut le faire avec mesure et
qu'il faut essayer de trouver la porte
de sortie maintenant mais oui j'en
appelle à la responsabilité ça servira
pas à grand chose je le crains mais de
de des situations de ceux qui sont
responsables des situations de blocage
aujourd'hui dans les raffinerie pour que
on retrouve une une vie normale et il
continueront leur action syndicale au
jour le jour quotidienne pour faire
avancer leurs idées dans l'entreprise
alors je l'ai dit tout à l'heure vous
participez au concertation on
négociation vous êtes venus au CNR vous
êtes dans le cycle aujourd'hui de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage vous y
participer celui des retraites aussi
mais je voudrais revenir à l'instant en
arrière aussi sur ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure parce que vous défendez
d'abord le monde du travail et la plus
grande injustice de ce pays c'est le
chômage or aujourd'hui j'appartiens
j'habite dans un département en
Bourgogne et le département voisins
d'ailleurs même mieux que nous ou le
chômage est tôt toute simple aujourd'hui
en dessous de 5 à 4,8 en Côte-d'Or on le
doit bien entendu à la conjoncture je
veux bien entendre mais aussi aux
mesures de politiquement je pense en
particulier à la politique de l'offre
qui a consisté en une baisse des impôts
de production baisse de la flat taxe
baisse de la peau sur les sociétés qui
ont permis de redonner de la
compétitivité aux entreprises de
retrouver le bilan bon présenté par
aujourd'hui pouvez-vous comment
pouvez-vous reprocher cette politique
qui consiste à baisser les charges les
entreprises je les entreprises qui
permettent aujourd'hui d'abord de
retrouver de l'activité de retrouver de
la croissance et dans le même temps de
lutter contre le chômage vous savez moi
j'étais de ceux qui ont soutenu le pack
de responsabilité dans un quinquennat
précédent qui était de d'aider les
entreprises à restaurer leur marge pour
recréer de l'emploi
parce que il y avait un problème
d'emploi énorme le problème c'est que de
responsabilité il y en a eu que d'un
seul côté
ce que je veux dire par là c'est qu'à un
moment donné moi je suis pour qu'il y a
des aides publiques aux entreprises mais
je suis pour quelle justifie lors de
leur utilisation et c'est pas le cas
c'est pas le cas en nombre de cas on le
voit sur la réparation de la richesse on
le voit parfois sur la qualité des
emplois vous savez quand même que les
emplois précaires sont en train de
repartir dans votre pays et donc sur la
baisse des impôts de production qui est
d'actualité je pense que on n'a pas
besoin de faire cette nouvelle baisse la
situation économique il vaut mieux
elle était meilleure évidemment il y a
un moment de conjoncture et vaudra mieux
cibler les entreprises vous savez moi
j'ai soutenu les aides aux entreprises
pendant la période du covid mais ce que
je dis c'est que ça peut pas être au
détriment d'un modèle de service public
qui est absolument important enfin on
s'est quand même aperçu pendant la crise
du covid que le tout budgétaire à
l'hôpital public n'était pas du tout de
la responsabilité de la seule majorité
qui était en place à ce moment-là c'est
des années de danse en termes de
politique de santé et bien elle nous
mettait en grosse difficulté on sait
tous qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
difficulté dans l'éducation c'est pas
moi qui le dis seulement c'est on lance
un conseil national de la Fondation sur
l'éducation on aura besoin de financer
ces politiques publiques et donc ça peut
pas se faire au détriment parce que
lorsqu'on dit il faut baisser les
charges c'est pas que des charges c'est
de la contribution bien commun des
entreprises et quand même temps on dit
il faut surtout pas toucher à la
fiscalité des entreprises ni même à la
fiscalité du capital on se met dans un
corner on n'arrive plus à financer
non pas seulement cela parce que j'ai
dit la contrepartie malgré de ses baies
c'est qu'il y a de la création d'emplois
de la création de cotisations de la
création de richesse la création de
richesse et l'auticia en contrepartie et
quand on voit les difficultés de
recrutement aujourd'hui des entreprises
on voit bien qu'il y a une demande qui
relance la machine qui relance leur
entreprise mais qui trouve pas le
personnel en fer donc je crois que dans
le même temps on peut pas dire
aujourd'hui
parce que vous m'avez parlé de la
discussion qui s'est ouvert ce matin sur
la la réforme de l'assurance chômage 30%
des difficultés de recrutement
aujourd'hui sont liées au fait qu'on n'a
pas les gens formés
il y en a 20% parce que les emplois sont
pas aux endroits où il y a les gens et
que la mobilité géographique c'est une
vue de l'esprit lorsque vous êtes en
demandeur d'emploi c'est c'est compliqué
pour de multiples raisons souvent parce
que d'ailleurs les emplois sont
localisés dans les endroits où les
logements sont pas forcément les plus
accessibles en termes de mission
aujourd'hui
non mais les démissions c'est des
démissions c'est une relation une
relation au travail 25% c'est lié à un
difficulté d'attractivité
c'est un problème d'attractivité salaire
de travail condition d'emploi on peut
pas faire l'impasse là-dessus on peut
pas faire l'impasse moi j'ai entendu
parfois les gens expliquer que il y
avait des travaux et c'est évidemment
extrêmement pénible et vous savez celui
qui vous le dit c'est celui dont les
premiers syndicats au sein de la CVT si
les syndicales de la propreté
Île-de-France de la sécurité privée de
France donc
voilà des métiers qui sont pas
spécialement faciles mais on peut pas
justifier que des métiers soient exercés
avec des salaires qui sont extrêmement
bas dans les entreprises ou les
conditions de la richesse créée est
extrêmement forte donc tout ça ça mérite
de réfléchir nous on a écrit avec les
autres organisations syndicales et les
organisations patronales à l'Association
des régions de France pour leur dire en
travaillant sur les freins à l'emploi
c'est quoi les freins à l'emploi
principaux c'est là qui sont du logement
moi je viens d'une région qui s'appelle
Saint-Nazaire ou quand j'étais
conseiller en insertion procès il y
avait 15% de chômage aujourd'hui il y en
a beaucoup moins un peu comme chez vous
mais il y a 5000 logements qui manquent
et donc pour faire venir des gens pour
travailler ce sera un problème le
deuxième problème c'est la mobilité
c'est la transport puis le troisième
problème c'est la garde d'enfant
quelqu'un qui trouve un emploi
aujourd'hui un peu partout en France
particulièrement Île-de-France mais pas
que loin s'en fout un peu partout en
France et qui a un enfant en bas âge en
garde est incapable de trouver un mode
de garde pour le mois de janvier et le
lundi prochain je veux dire et donc ça
veut dire que tout simplement il faut
qu'on travaille sur l'ensemble de ces
freins à l'emploi et je crois pas
simplement sur le fait de mettre la
pression sur les demandeurs
bon participer maintenant à la
concertation sur les retraites
concertation en trois cycles premier
cycle emplois des seigneurs deuxième
cycle les qualités troisième cycle la
faisabilité de les retraites
j'ai du mal à comprendre je vous ai
écouté tout à l'heure comment vous
pouvez aujourd'hui penser quand on
connaît la situation des finances quand
on connaît l'équilibre précaire des
retraites à terme que la France serait
le seul pays en Europe
à ce que qu'est-ce que c'est cette
îlot d'oasis de richesse on pourrait le
travailler jusqu'à 62 ans alors que même
les Suisses même les Suisses viennent de
voter il y a 10 jours la retraite à 65
ans pour les femmes vous allez me
répondre employabilité des seniors
j'entends bien ça ne me répond mais ce
que je peux dire là c'est que d'abord
une chose prouve que plus on travaille
longtemps plus les seniors sont employés
et pas moins parce que les gens vont pas
embaucher quelqu'un à 60 ans 60 ans
parce que quand on prend pas quelqu'un à
60 ans on sait qu'il va partir à 61 ou
62 ans si on sait qu'on va le garder 5
ans on l'emploi on l'emploi donc sur ce
site c'est la réalité
c'est vrai 55 ans aujourd'hui
puisque le premier cycle de concertation
est terminé sur leur poids des seniors
beaucoup de sujets il y aura beaucoup de
sujets dedans il y aura les carrières
longues les carrières hachées la
pénibilité etc et tout ces sujets mais
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez fait comme
proposition pour l'employabilité des
signes pour l'employabilité des seniors
les qui sont qu'on a fait on a fait 45
ans il y a un entretien d'abord sur
l'évaluation des compétences des seniors
ça on le fait pas parce que je vous
rappelle qu'à 45 ans d'ailleurs vous
êtes catégorisé Seigneur si on est
l'accès à la formation professionnelle
pour les personnes de plus de 5 ans 50
ans il est extrêmement difficile parce
qu'on considère qu'on va pas investir
sur quelqu'un de plus de 50 ans on fait
on propose qu'il y a des négociations
dans toutes les entreprises sur l'emploi
des seniors avec un un droit supplétif
si jamais les entreprises se mettaient
pas d'accord sur au sein de l'entreprise
entre les organisations syndicales et
l'employeurs sur la comment on maintient
de l'emploi des seniors comment on
embaucher seniors qui soit une
pénalisation des entreprises au fait
qu'il y a pas assez de seniors je suis
désolé moi je connais des entreprises
qui à partir de 55 ans fait tout font
tout pour faire partir les personnes
seniors soit parce que on leur dit qu'il
coûte trop cher soit qui sont plus
adapter aux postes de travail etc etc il
se passe quoi vous savez ce qui se passe
l'assurance chômage
il se passe l'invalidité d'ailleurs le
corps puisqu'on parle beaucoup du corps
à évaluer que grosso modo un transfert
un recul de l'âge légal c'est 3
milliards de plus à charge de
l'assurance chômage et un milliard et un
et quelques milliards sur les
dispositifs de santé en poids
supplémentaire pour eux pour ces régimes
là donc ça veut dire qu'il faut bien
travailler sur cette sur ce maintien
dans un poil des seniors et nous on
propose de le faire encore une fois par
le dialogue social mais s'il dit alors
comment la France pourrait être le seul
pays on travaillerait 62 ans j'ai déjà
entendu enfin plutôt lu dans l'interview
d'Édouard Philippe si au Parisien si si
il y a beaucoup de Français et ben tout
simplement parce que d'abord la
situation démographique et pas la même
deuxièmement la France elle travaille
pas elle s'arrête pas 62 ans de
travailler les Français ce sera 63 ans
ouais et que le rapport du corps dit par
l'évolution normale de la réforme
Touraine plus
l'entrée sur le marché du travail qui
est différenciée à terme c'est 64 et
quelques donc en fait je vais vous dire
ce qu'on est en train de faire on est en
train de faire un débat idéologique qui
va encore cliver la société quand on
pourrait faire quelque chose de beaucoup
plus naturel moi ma conception et la
conception de la CFDT depuis toujours y
compris quand on s'est engagé de la
forme difficile c'est que la question de
l'âge c'est un faux débat le vrai débat
c'est combien on travaille pour faire
valoir nos droits à la retraite et être
solidaires dans un système de solidarité
entre les générations parce que l'âge il
y en a pas un aujourd'hui si vous prenez
les
100000 derniers retraités qui sont
partis combien sont partis réellement le
jour de leur 62 ans très très peu parce
que la réalité est pas celle-là mais
vous avez raison il y a ça mais c'est
pas troublant quand même effectivement
de constater que tout le monde par plus
tard que nous que tout le monde
il y a la longé allongement de la durée
de vie oui mais
écoutez à partir du moment où le régime
de retraite se doit d'être équilibré la
sérénité n'a jamais fait l'économie
d'une réforme pour équilibrer le régime
de retraite ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y a pas le feu la preuve ce
patriar au début on a dit il va falloir
travailler plus longtemps par moins
qu'il ait des gouvernement parce qu'il
faudra financer d'autres politiques
publiques non je suis désolé c'est pas
c'est du gouvernement si si au début là
il a dit
c'est qu'à la fin ils ont rétropédaler
ce qu'on dépensera pas pour les
retraites en surcoût on pourra le
dépenser pour faire de l'autonomie moi
je propose qu'on dépense pas en surcoût
sur les retraites tout simplement
faisant une chose en faisant en sorte
que le taux d'emploi des seniors il soit
il soit augmenté et que une entreprise
ne puisse pas facilement se séparer
alors c'est fini vous restez avec nous
François Patriat pardon c'est fini
parce qu'on va rejoindre Jean-Baptiste
et merdjian tout de suite au Figaro pour
une ultime question à Laurent Berger
Jean-Baptiste oui Laurent Berger donc
une ultime question vendredi dernier les
étudiants en médecine manifestaient
contre le projet de quatrième année
d'étude effectuée en priorité dans les
déserts médicaux qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette 4e année les déserts
médicaux sont un vrai problème mais
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure la
santé ce n'est pas de l'écume
non je crois que aujourd'hui la santé
elle est financée par de la contribution
des uns et des autres c'est c'est un
fond de mutualisé et que il y a une
responsabilité qui soit mise sur
l'installation des médecins je suis pour
est-ce que c'est de la de l'obligation
c'est compliqué mais en tout cas il faut
de la forte incitation à les combler les
déserts médicaux vous savez dans le
mécontentement et dans l'angoisse dont
on a parlé on a beau parler beaucoup de
sujets la question du désert Medic mais
des déserts médical enfin du désert
médical ou des déserts médicaux elle est
posée pour nombre de Français et je
crois que il y a des solutions à trouver
et ce que est-ce que c'est forcément
vécu comme de la contrainte je sais pas
mais moi on va pas pouvoir rester sur la
même situation c'est à dire qu'on peut
pas avoir des installations
nombreuses sur un territoire et quasi
absente sur un autre il y a des endroits
où quand vous faites le tour de France
vous apercevez que ça devient une vraie
galère donc oui il faut de l'incitation
et là aussi il faut discuter avec les
les étudiants en médecine pour voir quel
est le meilleur la meilleure chose mais
ils seront payés par des fonds de
mutualisés donc il faut il faut les
inciter à les implanter un peu partout
en France vous avez la réponse à votre
question pas de relance
pardon
incitation pas de cote de coercition
vous vous dites souvent Laurent Berger
que vous faites des Tours de France vous
étiez inquiets ces derniers mois vous
sentiez mais qu'est-ce que vous sentez
là dans le fond si on veut demander la
radioscopie du français aujourd'hui
c'est quoi
disparaître parce qu'on a tendance à
parler de là où c'est difficile mais il
y a aussi toute une toute une partie des
travailleurs et parfois même d'ailleurs
évidemment modestes parce qu'il y a pas
que que le niveau de revenus dans la vie
il y a qui sont plutôt bien dans leur
vie heureusement mais je sens que je
sens de beaucoup d'inquiétudes et je
sens une aspiration à ce que les
solutions soient trouvées et on n'aura
pas d'autres voix pour les trouver que
de mettre les sujets sur la table
d'essayer de pas se raconter d'histoires
les uns les autres et puis trouver des
solutions mais et l'autre élément c'est
que je pense que les Français sont
beaucoup plus près et d'ailleurs y
compris les salariés dans leur
entreprise la participer à la mise en
oeuvre de choix collectifs qu'on ne les
ai associe vraiment je crois qu'il y a
une volonté d'engagement beaucoup plus
forte que ce qu'elle est exploité mais
oui la fameuse archipelisation la
tribalyse
on sent des territoires très différents
les uns des autres je crois que Monsieur
patriam dira pas l'inverse
mais et oui on peut sentir de la colère
on peut sentir ici ou là de la lassitude
ce qui est encore pire parfois mais mais
faut pas surfer là-dessus pour expliquer
que ce serait enfin ça devient parfois
cette espèce de recherche de c'est quoi
l'état de la France et des citoyens
est-ce qu'ils vont mal comment faut pas
que ça devienne jouer ici quoi faut que
ça vienne mobilisateur vous voyez ce que
je veux dire
collectif et la solidarité existe
toujours alors qu'on
et bien sûr ils existent et puis il
faudra faire confiance aussi aux jeunes
qui sans doute sur un certain nombre de
sujets verront les choses un peu
différemment et et et je crois qu'il
faut écouter ça y compris sur les
évolutions du travail on a un peu parlé
ce soir nous on a fait des propositions
d'assises du travail pour réfléchir à ça
merci Laurent Berger merci beaucoup
François patriaz d'avoir accepté ce
débat on se retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
d'audition publique sur LCP Public Sénat
bonne soirée à tous